hello konnichiwa everybody pity pay
forever I'm back baby back to play some
pop G finally you guys know I love this
game I've always been curious how does
this game translate into mobile how
could they possibly make this game
mobile well we're about to find out what
why does the graphics look good oh my
god the graphics for real though why
does it look better than PC okay all
right I don't know if I could disk too
much this is a branded video after all
the return of I love asked to the
legendary account name is already take
29 how about that I love is 29 name is
already taken fantastic how about I love
ask two dollar sign name is okay I love
ass nine nine nine nine nine
okay we're good we're good we're solid
oh look at that
graphics set to high because of my
wonderful phone sailor uniforms that's
kawaii
can I get those holy hell I'm impressed
I want to do solo right I always play
solo but then again what if you can talk
to other people oh you can that could be
fun oh my god wait what how do I turn
this is not bad probably like the
recording is not as good because
recording and playing at the same time
this is totally doable oh wait how do i
sprint I just pulled it up fast higher
hey buddy how you doing
can you hear me brother do you hear me
do you know doorway huh do you know that
way yeah don't make me get angry all
right wait we should practice guns
actually [ __ ] to lane let's begin
there's hundred people how do I drop out
I'm so nervous
this is like the first time I played pub
gene turn on voice turn on voice chat
kidding the car guys come on
lol I'm when I'm the only one
walking this is great all right well
this is the first game we got a drop
island right military island here we go
okay so how does this work then how do I
get forward well I figured that out but
thank you game I need to go forward oh I
look up okay I got it [ __ ] yeah that's
not great I don't even know how to shoot
I don't know how to pick up items but
here we go perfect landing everybody you
can find items and buildings thank you
game so how do I open door Auto nice
someone's already been here fantastic Oh
all right oh my god it's so intuitive
okay we got a vest oh my god if I see an
enemy now I'm gonna poop myself okay
that's good come on I can't I can't not
not kill anyone my first game here we go
scar excellent so now how do I use it
no no that is not what I wanted to do
great now they all know where I am okay
scar select the scar oh god someone's
gonna come to hurt yes okay okay
close this now close this this is how
the pros play all right I hear he's
right there I don't know can you jump
out windows and such why do I keep
hearing him easy okay how do I pick it
up okay what oh oh he's just taking all
of it great I need the compressor pro
I'm a pro guys okay we're in the circle
too and gaming I wonder if the SKS is
usable at all I feel like I should just
go with spam weapons like how would I
possibly use a sniper I gotta say them
super impressed with how playable it is
that was pretty skeptical okay let me
just say that I wasn't sure if it would
work I feel like I should just go UMP
and this is no way I'm gonna be able to
snipe anyone so how do I use meds and
stuff okay well that was easy I heard
someone Oh someone's coming so bad okay
we should probably start thinking about
how we want to get out of here and
gaming I feel like since I'm wearing
headphones it's so easy for me to hear
other people car 98 that would be so fun
to snipe in this game I can definitely
see myself getting addicted to this do
they have volt thing though do they have
vaulting can jump okay
oh god we're about to drive for the
first time see how this goes I'm sure
this will be fine
okay so tribe fantastic oh okay map we
need to cross the bridge
- whoa look I still drive better than
Brad how about that first how am I
playing this on mobile I don't
understand it all right let's make sure
no one kills us at the bridge bad things
can happen at bridges unless you're
careful guys got to make sure you cross
them as as fast as possible all right
new map we're pretty good in the middle
I don't know where to go here maybe put
[ __ ] say hi to some pachinko people or
maybe here yeah these buildings are
really good man I miss playing pub G I
used to play every day for hours and
hours and hours
it was almost getting pathetic no one's
looted here I mean I'll take it so how
do I close doors uh oh yeah this is the
most exciting bit of the game like the
second circle does nothing happens
I wonder if an m16 is good I wonder like
what guns are good I don't know it looks
good though
it runs smooth like I'm recording at the
same time yeah someone's been in here
though there's still 60 people alive I
don't think I should be that proud of
myself I killed the guy that was walking
away from me while being shot all right
I think we're good on stuff actually
oh you can't vault okay Oh someone's
shooting me exactly thought I heard
someone where is you that was me
shooting I didn't mean to I panicked
whoops he won't know where I am now
there yes I see him
[Music]
[Laughter]
I love ass nine nine nine nine nine
forever I think I'm ready to go pro
pretty much at any given moment this is
my first game guys the problem here is
that I really have to poo but I also
realize that's technically not a problem
anymore
I can just go BRB guys god damn it jack
I'm still alive I'm still alive I wonder
how good it is to lay just prone I feel
like that has to be pretty Oh peeing a
game like this
so how many people are left I can't see
cuz I'm recording over it so this is
this is pro strats right here guys
what's happening over there we're still
in the circle oh and I can just zoom in
on it okay so that area is really good
actually
we're trying it there why am I talking
to myself like I'm listening to myself
alright just go or maybe that house
there no it's not in enough well that's
a stone still a better driver than Brad
alright we're just gonna come crashing
burning close ah that's not what I want
you to do oh my god I'm such a pleb I'm
so nervous
Oh someone's coming if you get in here
I'm gonna spray your butt to butt cheeks
this is not camping this is tactical
sitting oh I see
got them a little bit it's a little oh
shoot him what's happening 9 for life
for life for life hey it's getting hard
to see like I need to hold it close to
my face I'm not playing on an iPad
honestly I might just invest in it at
some form of tablet just to play this
game oh there's the drop right there I
feel like I have such an advantage just
playing with headphones like these kids
don't know what's happening okay we're
still in the circle I don't know how
many people are laughs I can't see I say
we just chill
oh hell peg oh that's really nearby
shots I'm so in it dude this is so fun
oh they're up there in the hill oh there
is oh my god they're fine oh he's gonna
loot he's gonna loot I can't Oh
tag him he doesn't know I'm shooting him
or where I am
oh there's another guy right there dude
I'm tagging people left and right
maybe sniping isn't so bad because no
one's moving
oh god speaking of moving I got a move
Oh someone's name by
can you stop yes yes I am the best
blacks one two three you can lick me all
right I need to loot something my goal
now is basically not just get the ammo
I'm a little tempted to get the 4x but
you just can't get everything you want
in life wait you can sprint while you
crawl oh my god do you feel the tension
do you feel this we're living the snake
life everybody we're gonna snake this to
victory why do I have less lag on my
phone then on my computer I am so no no
no no oh god that's so far we have so
far to crawl there's nothing there where
is everyone I don't see anyone guys
please if I see someone should we shoot
this guy that's the real question
I think we should wait he must see as
though I don't think it does actually am
I in or not it's kind of hard to tell
what's he doing
it's like strafing oh my god I'm so
nervous
wait he's shooting someone else the best
gamer on the planet like this video
right now I mean I'm proud wow ss+
everybody I love ass has returned first
game everybody that was super fun dude
I'm shaking it's like when I first
played pub G the first time you know it
really takes me back to like three
months ago guys check out pop G mold by
a link in the description add me as a
friend I love ass 99.999 maybe we can
play together this is super fun the game
is free on mobile so definitely check it
out and download it so much fun playing
this and yeah that's it for me for now
goodbye